tulip sadiq has been uh has been
tweeting in the last
few few moments nazanin is at the
airport in tehran and on her way home i
came into politics to make a difference
and right now i'm feeling like i have
more details to follow and of course
tulip who's the mp for hampstead and
kilburn has been following this for some
years now she's been in constant contact
with nazanin's husband richard who of
course we've had on sky news many many
times during his very long ordeal for a
long time been separated not just from
his wife but also from their young
daughter who was in iran with her
grandparents so that she could see her
mum regularly while she was in prison
there and then came to the uk to take up
a place at primary school so reunited
with her father but painfully aware of
her mother's predicament being under
house arrest there
in tehran of course one of the reasons
we've been so cautious is first of all
because there have been so many false
dawns before suggesting she may be
released and then it's not happened only
last april she was given another year
added to her sentence and it felt this
may just be endless the other reason of
course is what's happening what's
happened behind the scenes we know this
morning and we've heard for some time
from the government that they
acknowledge owing the iranians 400
million pounds for a tank deal back in
1979 the iranians paid for the tanks
didn't receive them because the shah of
iran was deposed and the islamic
revolution happened so they are owed
that money the british government say
liz trust wouldn't confirm whether it
had been paid this morning
how it could be paid given that the iran
is subject to uk financial sanctions is
unclear there are some suggestions in
the newspapers that we have not
confirmed that it was paid in non-cash
terms perhaps something given in lieu of
cash so all of that to be explained but
we are still awaiting formal
confirmation uh from from the foreign
office about that but it all sounds very
very positive for nazanin for anushay
asuri who is said to be with her and
potentially for a third
dual national who liz trust mentioned
this morning murad tabaz a businessman
who had also been detained so
potentially all three of them going to
be finally getting out of iran this
morning and nazanin being reunited with
richard and her daughter gabriella now
seven years old she's missed so much of
her childhood and will just be
desperate to start life with them again
start afresh